president Trump insulting Haiti so I  thought it was only fair to give  Haitians a chance to return the favor  Toby in viscid RC mas Mushaf you keep a  video silly citizen even more appeal  belt al Gough receive a zero Vince Viola  Liuzzo - bleep okay male voice damu  Chavez near Oprah new email about actors  of vanilla may us even appeal democracy  it does in the memory Tituba Sebastian  to the Guardian University Oprah okay  Nadia my food hurry hurry men I will  play event League law for immigration  reform issues issues like a tea  coated in Haiti airing this Saturday  January 27th at 10 o'clock p.m. we'll be  right back  Sharon Stone is gonna be joining  you